ورحمه الله وبركاته بسم الله الرحمان
الرحيم والحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
افضل الانبياء وسيد المرسلين سيدنا محمد
عليه وعلى اله وصحبه افضل الصلاه واتم
التسليم
اهلا وسهلا حضور تت تحيه لكم اولا
[تصفيق]
لدى الجميع سوى تمرين بسيط قبل ما ندخل ان
تطال برايك عوده نشاط الاجواء شويه هودي
الجميع الله يعطيكم العافيه بهذا الشكل
كده الجميع معانا الجميع معاي في التمرين
الجميع جاهز اوكي
يقول واحد اثنين ثلاثه وصف المفروض كلنا
نساوي نفس الشيء 12 12 12 12 ممتاز تحيه
لكم مره اخرى
طبعا هذه تحيه عزاء لك لانه انا اقول نقول
واحد اثنين ثلاثه وكلكم سفكت وبعد واحد
تعرف وليس الكل صفق بعد 12 لاننا كبشر
يتاثر ب سلوكيات الاشخاص وافعالهم اكثر
بكثير مما نتاثر باقوالهم وحاول اليوم في
العرض البسيط اللي حتم اذ ان نستعرض تجارب
افضل مما نتكلم كلام نظري لذلك تبدا في
دراسه اجرتها جامعه هارفرد هذه الدراسه
تعتبر الاطول في تاريخها عمرها اكثر من
خمسه وسبعين سنه تتعاقب عليها اجيال
واجيال من اجل ان تقدم هذه الدراسه لنا
اليوم الدراسه استهدفت اكثر من سبعمائه
واربعه وعشرين شخص بدات تجيز حياتهم من
امراض سطاشر سنه الى مماتهم
فكانوا اول سؤال يسالون ما الذي تعتقد انه
سوف يعطيك السعاده في هذه الحياه فكانت
الاجابات
الاموال
وكثير منهم جاوب الجواب الاخر وهو الشهره
الشهر
سوف تعطيني السعاده والمفاجاه بهذه
الدراسات ودرسوا حياه اكثر من شخص من 19
الى سبعه وثمانين منهم ومنهم اكثر
لم تكن المال ولم يكن الشهره
كثير ممن قالوا المال او الشهره هي التي
سوف تمنحنا السعاده في الحياه لمجالس وهم
في النهايه اجابوا باجابات مختلفه قبل
مماتهم
كثير ممن حصلوا على المال قالوا المال ما
اعطانا السعاده لكن ان بغاها لما يتوقع ان
القوات سعيدين وكثير من منك امتلكوا
الشهره وجدوا ان الشهره لم تعطهم هذه
السعاده السعاده كانت عن طريق العلاقات
الشخصيه التي يبنيها الانسان مع الناس من
حوله العلاقات الشخصيه الجانب الاسرى
الجانب العائلي الجانب المهني هذه هي التي
سوف تعطينا السعاده الحقيقيه في حياتنا
ومن اجل ان نكون اشخاص لدينا علاقات قويه
ومتينه في هذه الحياه لابد ان يكون لدينا
شخصيات تنعكس من داخلنا على الاخرين ونكون
هذه الشخصيات لذلك ابدا في مقال قراتها
منظمه ناسا الفضائيه
كانت تستهدف ثلاثه من رواد الفضاء
وجهوا سؤال لل ثلاثه منهم كانوا يعملوا في
تركيب المسامير والصواميل الخاصه في ابواب
مركبه الفضاء سالوا الاول قالوا له ايش
تسوي كلهم انا اركب المسامير والصواميل
الخاصه ب مركبه الفضاء
بينما لما سالوا الثاني قالوا له
كلهم اني ا ساهم في صنعه مركبه فضائيه عمل
الاول هو عمل الثاني ولكن المفاجاه كانت
في سؤال هبل الثالث كان ولازال السوي كلهم
اني اشارك ناس الفضائيه في اقتحام الفضاء
الاول له نظره والثاني له نظره والثالث له
كل منا له هذه النظره الخاصه
العمل واحد وكل واحد منا لديه مجال عمله
انت كيف تنظر لنفسك كيف تشوف اداء كل
رسالتك والشيء اللي تقدم في هذه الحياه هل
انت مثل الاول وال مثل الثاني ولا مثل
الاخر الثالث كيف تستطيع ان تصور رسالتك
للعالم هذه مسؤوليتنا نحن وليست مسؤوليه
الاخرين اعتقادنا اننا نعمل اعمال عظيمه
فيما تقوم فيه بهذه الحياه هي مسؤوليتنا
نحن وليست مسؤوليه الاخرين
وكثير من الاخرين من الناس اليوم ليس
لديهم اعتقاد ذاتي عن ما يقوم فيه انه
عظيم فبالتالي للاسف تكون ضحايا هذه
الامور هي القبور الاحلام اغلبها اليوم
لها واحد هي القبور البشريه ناس لم تؤمن
بنفسها ابتداء ومن ثم كان القبر هو مكان
الاحلام التي دارت في ذهنه ما
استحي اني اقول في يوم من الايام كنت في
نهايه المرحله المتوسطه في هذا المكان هذا
المكان هذه صورتي تشاهدون ي في الخلف امسك
الورقه في الاذاعه المدرسيه
ومؤمن في نفسي انني استطيع ان اقدم رساله
للعالم مفيده واستطيع ان اطور من مجتمعي
شايفين في وجه ممكن متململه في ناس اللي
وراء اصلا طفشانين هذا ازاله سيقول بس بعد
ثلاث سنوات فقط تمت دعوتي من المدرسه لكي
اقدم محاضره لاكثر من خمسمائه شخص في
المدرسه وفيما بعد على مستوى التعليم تم
ترشيحي لالقاء كلمه في الغرفه التجاريه
لانني ابتداء حسيت انه فعلا عندي رساله
ممكن اكمل فيها في السنوات بين الصوره
الاولى وصوره ل بعدها ولكن هذا كله حي لما
تدخل الحياه الجامعيه في الحياه الجامعيه
الجامعه ما تعرف انت كان عندك فلازم تبنى
من جديد وايضا كان تحدي
الموهبه وهذه الرساله التي تريد ان تقدم
العالم يجب ان تنشرها من جديد
ايضا توالت ولله الحمد المراكز الاولى في
القاء العرب والخطابه في الجامعه الى ان
تم ترشيحه لمحاوره سمو الامير خالد الفيصل
كاول طالب سعودي يحاول سمو الامير خالد
الفيصل لكن دائما اشاهد صور من هذا النوع
في الملتقيات ومناصب والناس اللي اصحاب
الانجازات قلت عبد الله انت في الالقاء
والخطابه كيف ممكن تاخذ صوره مع سمو ملكي
موجود في البلد كانت عن طريق الشيء اللي
ركزت عليه وتم ترشيح الحوار وفيما بعد في
الصحف
هذه ايضا صوره هذه تغريد تاليه تذكروا
المحاضره اللي كانت قدمتها التاريخ موجود
في تويتر فى عام 2012 هذه التغريده الاولى
اليمين وتعمد نشر تغريده ثانيه
فيما بعد وقت سمو الامير خالد الفيصل كانت
في 2017 المده 5
سنوات خمس سنوات ما كانت بسيطه ما كان
الشخص يعني
زي ما يقول وعلى طول ترشح وتحاول سمو
الامير في اشياء كثيره الناس تسويها ولكن
للاسف في المجتمع عندنا شيء او بدنا ناخذ
الثمره مباشره لا يحتاج ل لسنه وسنتين
وثلاثه واربعه ممكن عشر سنوات لما توصل
بين الصوره هذه والصوره اللي قبلها في
الاذاعه ثلاث سنوات اذا الموضوع كله يمكن
ثمانيه سنوات تقريبا
ولانني مؤمن ان الاشياء لا تاتي صدفه
اليوم كان موعد جدا جميل لانني البارح
تحديدا تم ترشيحي من نادي بوست ماستر
العالمي للخطابه لا ننافس على مستوى
المنطقه في ال القاء العربي والخطاب
شكرا لكم
اشهى رؤيتنا الخاصه التي نريد ان نقدم على
العالم هي الميزه التي تميزت على العالم
تستطيع ان تضع نظاره لهذا العالم و يرى
العالم بصوره مختلفه دائما ما اقول ان
الفقير هو اكثر شخص يستطيع ان يمنح العطاء
لهذا العالم
الرجل او المراه الذين عانوا من اضطهاد
عنصري هم اكثر الناس
الذين يستطيعون ان يصنعون رؤيه واضحه في
هذا العالم
لازاله الفوارق المجتمعيه بين الشعوب
البنت اللي كانت امها ما هي من تبذلها وما
ترعاها بالشكل المناسب هي اكثر الشخص
يستطيع ان يكون ام يعطي الحنان لبنات ح
وابنائه
الابن الذي لم يجد
الرفيق الصحيح من والده ولم يجد الدعم
المناسب من ابيه هو اكثر شخص يستطيع ان
يمنح العمل ابنائه فيما بعد كل واحد مننا
اللي بت لانه لم يخطئ الذي اعطال موقف في
هذه الحياه ما غلط كل واحد فينا لديه سبب
عميق يستطيع ان يعمل من اجله من اجل تحقيق
رؤيه عظيمه في هذا العالم
هذا الجبل الى تعثر الى ان وصل الى ان وصل
هو اكثر شخص يستطيع ان يساعد الاخرين من
اجل ان يصعدوا هذا الجبل في عباره تقول
فاقد الشيء لا يعطيه
اسمحوا لي اقول لكم ان هذه العباره خطا
فاقد الشيء قد يكون في بعض الاحيان هو
افضل من يعطيه
لما وصلتني هذه الرساله دعوه بين ثلاثه
اشهر من الان
فصاعدا الكلمه ما وصل لهذه المرحله
ومااعرف ايش اكتب هنا انا ابغي اتكلم عن
التضحيه بس مني عارف اشياء عبد الله تبقى
تقول عشان تشعر الاخرين ان كانسان وان
كانت تمر بظروف كثيره وانه التقرير
والاشياء هذه كلها صحيح نجاحات ولكن كلنا
بشر في النهايه واذا ما كنت اشعر اشعر كم
حقيقه بشريه اليوم انا ما اعتبر نجحت في
هذا الخطاب لان الجميع يستطيع ان يسمي
نفسه سويته اكثر بكثير وكنت اوصل هذا يقول
الاشتباك كلمه تضحيه وخلاص اجلها يتاجل
الى قبل خمسه ايام الى الان لم اتفاجئنا
وعرفنا انه في وقت حساس جدا وضيق وما
حنقدر نلحق
حضور تدي الكريم ايتها الكلمات انا اليوم
موجود في ليله امتحان فاينل في برنامج
الدكتور الصيدلي في جامعه الملك عبد
العزيز
اثرت اني اكون موجوده اليوم عشان اقول انه
كلنا عندنا تضحيات الامور في الحقيقه هذه
ما تمشي بشكل اللي احنا نبغا دائما اليوم
في عندك دعوه ولايتها الاختبار وبكره عندك
اختبار الطيب حيث يعتبر ولا حتيجي طيب
الاختبار احساس يصل الى ابغى اقوله انه
اذا فيه شخص واحد فقط اليوم استفاد من
الكلام اللي قلته هذا س يكفيني ويخليني
اضحى باشياء اخرى ايضا يعطيكم العافيه
ختاما
في كتاب
ده امتى للكاتب وت وتهمل يقول لا تذهب الى
قبرك وان تتحمل اجمل ما في داخلك يسلم كل
الخير الذي بداخلك الى هذا العالم افعل
شيئا جيدا
ينشر علما نافعا وحقق هدفا عميقا المثل
الصيني يقول اذا اردنا ان نرى شجره عظيمه
بهذا الشكل فافضل وقت كان لزراعتها قبل
عشره سنوات
وثاني افضل وقتل زراعتها هو اليوم فلنبدا
جميعا اليوم بتحقيق ما نريد يعطيكم
العافيه
ام